- [Instructor] In the
last video, we started
with the story of the
Patriarchs in Genesis.
How Abraham settles his people in Canaan,
but eventually they get enslaved in Egypt.
According to the Old Testament,
that enslavement lasts
for over 500 years until we
have the emergence of Moses
whom we also spoke
about in the last video.
The next four books of the
Hebrew Bible which are often
given authorship to Moses.
These really talk about Moses
freeing the Jewish people
from enslavement,
getting the Commandments,
the Law, from God, and
eventually bringing the people
so that they can resettle back in Canaan.
As I mentioned in the last
video, these first five books
of the Hebrew Bible,
also the first five books
of the Christian Old
Testament, they are referred to
as the Torah, and they are
given authorship to Moses
although historians are doubtful of that.
Even the historicity to
the degree to which these
are historical characters
are significantly debated.
We have the Jewish people,
according to Biblical accounts,
now in Canaan.
As we go into the rest of
this video, we're getting into
more of a historical period
with the first significant kings
of the Israelites.
Now we're getting into
the first millennium BCE.
The people, the Israelites,
are settled in Canaan.
In the 11th century, BCE you
have King Saul comes to power.
He's considered to be the
first significant king,
or the first king really
of a united kingdom
of Israel and Judah.
This is King Saul.
He is then succeeded by King
David who is his son-in-law.
It was a very continuous succession.
David is considered a significant figure
in Judaism and Christianity and Islam.
He's considered a warrior,
poet, philosopher.
He really strengthens and
really unifies the kingdom.
He's succeeded by his son, King Solomon.
King Solomon is famous in
Biblical accounts for his wisdom.
He's also known for creating
the First Temple in Jerusalem.
As we will see, this
First Temple in Jerusalem,
the way that I have marked
it off on this timeline,
the green is periods according
to Biblical accounts,
then later according to
historical accounts as well.
When the Jewish people were
for the most part not in Canaan
where they were in captivity,
or they were being enslaved.
They were in exile some place else.
The white that I show here,
this is the enslavement in Egypt,
this is going to be the
Babylonian captivity
that we're going to talk about shortly.
Then the white, this is
when we have the existence
of the temples in Jerusalem.
The First Temple in Jerusalem,
this is a depiction of it,
was built by Solomon.
Now the unified kingdoms Judah
and Israel don't last beyond
these three kings.
Shortly thereafter, it gets
fragmented into two kingdoms.
The kingdom of Judah and
the kingdom of Israel.
The kingdom of Israel
is going to be overrun
by the Neo-Assyrians in 722
when they refuse to pay tribute
to the Neo-Assyrian king.
The kingdom of Judah essentially
becomes a client-state
of the Assyrians.
It's important to keep
in mind even though these
are called kingdoms for
most of this history,
they are client-states to larger powers
whether it's the
Assyrians, the Babylonians,
the Egyptians, the Seleucid.
They keep being client-states.
They also have some degree
of autonomy which is why
they are called kingdoms.
In 722, you have the kingdom
of Israel being overrun
and many of the Jewish people
having to go into exile
and being held captive
by the Neo-Assyrians.
Then as we get into the 6th century BCE,
you have the famous Babylonian Conquest,
The Neo-Babylonian Conquest
of Nebuchadnezzar the Second,
who conquers Judah.
Once again, this is really a side battle
between the Neo-Babylonians
and the Egyptians,
and we talk about that in other videos.
That takes us to the
Babylonian captivates.
This is a picture here of Jerusalem,
and maybe as equally important,
that First Temple of Solomon
being destroyed and the
Jewish people being taken
into captivity where they are taken
from Jerusalem to Babylon.
They're held in captivity, a
significant fraction of them
are held in captivity, in
Babylon from this period
from around 597, 586 BCE
until Babylon is conquered
by Cyrus the Great, conquered
by the Achaemenid Persians
that we talk about in another video.
Once again, the end of the
captivity is really a side effect
of larger battles and conquests going on.
But Cyrus the Great frees
the Jewish people in 538 BCE.
This is the end of the
Babylonian captivity.
He resettles them back in
Jerusalem, and his assessors
assist in the rebuilding of the temple.
Then you have the Second
Temple of Jerusalem.
You often will hear Second Temple Judaism
because this is the period
now where the Jewish people
are resettled in Jerusalem.
They are rebuilding that
Second Temple that a lot
of the Old Testament
takes its modern form.
Now this is going to last
for several hundred years.
As I mentioned the kingdom
of Judea is a client-state
of all of these various empires.
It eventually becomes a
client-state of the Roman Empire
as we get into the end of
the first millennium BCE.
As we get to 70 CE, so this
is shortly after the time
of Jesus, you have the
first Jewish-Roman War
sometimes referred to
as the Jewish Revolt.
In that, the Romans
destroy the Second Temple.
This is really significant,
the Second Temple
as we mentioned it starts getting rebuilt
at the end of the captivity and famously
gets really, nicely constructed as we get
into the First Century BCE.
Then in 70 CE, Jerusalem
is destroyed again.
This time by the Romans.
This is the beginning
of the Jewish Diaspora
where they are exiled for,
now we're talking thousands
of years, from Rome.
They spread through the Roman
Empire and other empires,
and we talk more about
that in other videos.
This is a significant thing
because now the Jewish people
are for the most part dispersed.
They don't have a temple, and
you don't see a significant
resettlement of the Jewish
people into this area
until we get to the 20th century.